why was Heidi the one Heidi is
everything I'm not
I would kill me if I had to date me
she's so sensitive that I have to be
careful sometimes what is with you today
we see you're bickering with Heidi
Rhodes parenting their kids Lu and
Phoenix and opening up about their life
together but they're still not sure
about marriage what is a current status
of your relationship right now are
having an ongoing dialogue that's what
I'll say um you know we just we come
from very different backgrounds and I
think to a certain extent right that's
what makes it work never knew you were
with Heidi for seven years
I mean well is that something that you
tried for a long time to keep private so
when we were going through the adoption
process there's only 14 states in
America right now where same-sex couples
can adopt and I always knew that I
wanted to adopt but I didn't know
exactly what path I was gonna take so I
did keep my personal life very private
until I knew what was gonna happen I
love you Phoenix tell us about your
children Heidi gave birth to your son
and then a week later you got your
daughter I'd been trying to adopt for
about two years we got matched with a
child
the next day Heidi came downstairs and
said I'm pregnant we ended up getting
matched with Lou and my son was born Lou
got her visa and they both came home the
same week for Mother's Day open about
her sexuality today but as a teen
Jillian was conflicted until she saw
Madonna's video justify my love I was
homophobic cuz I obviously didn't know
that I was gay and I was like that's
gross it's disgusting that's weird and
what she did that I was like oh that's
not okay that's not gross you're
disgusting and then it kind of allowed
me to figure out who I was you try this
crap on that same demanding drillmaster
still shows up on just Jillian but we're
also discovering a woman just trying to
balance it all you either hate me or
you're inspired by me and the reality is
if you hated me you go home she's normal
she's not so bad if you were inspired by
me it's like oh she's normal
you